hi everyone I'm Donna and I'm a data
scientist in over lytx which is a
started in the field of the healthcare
and what we're trying to do is to
provide monitoring solution for elderly
people so for example we predict if
someone has fallen dehydration or all
kind of abnormal scenarios
so this is our systems look like so you
can see the watch I'm wearing here it's
the one in the picture well all kind of
smart bands and watches and they have
all kind of signals like heart rate and
acceleration data that are broadcasted
through the phone or some kind of
gateway to the cloud then we extract and
clean this data in order to create the
detection algorithms so the detection
events are coming back to the cloud and
then are sent as notifications to a
caregiver application so if someone
lives in a nursing home
the nurse who takes care or other staff
can see in their tablet or on their
phone all kind of notification of the
algorithms I just explained so this is
our flow problem and actually one day 1
of our client write the request they
asked us to provide a kind of emergency
button mechanism they wanted it because
so the elderly people could call help
not just relying on
our algorithm just in all kind of
emergency situations such as fire alarm
or something else so great the watch i
wear actually has a physical button you
can see there great so mission
accomplished
well not really apparently when you push
this button nothing is really happening
no alarm is set and the only thing that
happens actually is a really short
vibration yes this is exactly like if a
tree falls in a forest and no one is
around to hear it does it make any sound
so of course we thought of talking with
our watch provider in order for them to
help us to find a solution for that
because we really wanted to use this
button on the watch but they said to us
that they cannot do it because they
don't have that okay so we started to
think about other possible solutions the
first solution without all was a
necklace with a physical button the
problem with that solution was that it's
actually really make the product the
product expensive and can confuse and
bothered elderly people that now have to
wear to wearable device devices instead
of one so another solution that we
thought of that actually implemented was
create some kind of tapping mechanism on
the screen on the screen of the watch
like tapping 1 2 3 4 5 to set the alarm
but of course we're talking about
elderly people and
our client didn't like this solution
either because you cannot teach an old
dog new tricks so we still have a
problem okay so my boss the vp R&D came
to me and said hmm Donna what do you
think about trying to predict the
emergency calls from the bottom
vibration and I like said to him
hmm do you may like extracting the
acceleration signals that are coming
back from the button vibration into the
watch and by that predict the emergency
call he'd like yeah
that's exactly what I mean okay you can
imagine my first response was what this
is crazy it's not a data science problem
it's an SDK problem so please talk with
a white provider again and push them
harder and he said yeah of course I'm
going to do that again again and again
but meanwhile please you should at least
try because this is our best chance for
that time that left to provide the
solution I thought about it and okay
it's kind of an interesting challenge
it's crazy won by an interesting one and
I accepted the challenge so those are
some of our positive examples you can
see here the acceleration data of X Y
and that all the three X's on the space
and what else you can see here is the
actual vibration is the is taking just
half a second so it's actually really
difficult if you can see you know just
you can see here the half a second
and of the exact button-pusher some
other examples so it's kind of hard and
they various examples and those are the
negative examples this is pretty easy
just the hand is still it's very easy to
different from the positive examples but
those examples I are quite difficult
ones so what I actually did is to take
all the signals to concatenate them to
one vector and try in different kind of
with those friends of the data what you
see here is a about just three seconds
but I tried all kind of numbers in my
algorithm the algorithm that I first
thought to use was logistic regression
and the reasons were that it's actually
a really really simple one simple model
that you can easily implement in a
mathematical equation and since I didn't
know where eventually the algorithm is
going to be implemented it's a really
nice solution become because a
mathematical equation can be implemented
on the phone on the watch or on the
server another thing that I mentioned
was that I actually had very short time
to collect the data so what I thought of
doing is to take every button push
example and kind of duplicate it by
moving the sliding window in few frames
let's say 10 samples from each parent
push the problem with that is that when
I split the data set into a training set
and validation sets
it's probably that I will contaminate
contaminate my validation set since a
lot of the data that is in the training
set or will have very similar examples
in my validation set so that's not good
because it's overfitting so in order to
solve this problem scikit-learn has been
an excellent algorithm called route
cross validation so in order to explain
the algorithm let's assume every button
push has only one feature X you can see
here and let's see only have 12 examples
of I'm sorry I have only four examples
two of Balon bush and two that are not
for this example I just multiply every
button push into three samples you can
see the first three samples are positive
and belong to the same group one ii
decide the next three samples belongs
all to the group two and there are
always negative and so on
so just for the example if we want to
splits for our cross-validation the
algorithm will make sure two separate
samples that belong to put samples that
belong to the same group in the same set
for example the first six samples will
go in the first split to the first set
and the less examples to the last set
and for the other split the same back
opposite way so those are the initial
results of the setup that I explained to
you you can see here that actually my
true positive rate then the algorithm
and managed to predict is quite good
it's only about 4% of false negative
rate there are reco here if you
calculate it it's 96 percent so it's a
did very good on the positive side and
the problem here is actually the
negative set because you can see here
that the false positive relative rate
the false positive rate the relative
number from the entire set is quite high
it's about 12% the way that I decided to
choose the model ways to use f1 score
you can see here also this is the
measurement is quite good for initial
results I think and the reason that I
chose specifically this measurement is
because the f1 score if you will play a
little bit with this equation you can
prove yourself at all you get a
representation for the actually three
interesting numbers the true positives
the false positive and the false
negative in those kind of problems in
the real world like button push when you
have a lot of negative data and most of
the doc I showed you one example that
was really simple to predict and most of
the data looks like this
I actually I'm not interested in the
true negative number because those are
most of the examples and the algorithm
can handle it quite well so this why I
really like f1 score in those kind of
problems
after doing some math I actually
realized that the 12 percent false
positive rate
means that I'm going to get 180 wrong
predictions every minute airs user and
it's quite a bit right so actually I got
much less I got only four false positive
prediction every minutes per user and
only if I really tried to create a false
positive event how do I know it because
in order to check how the algorithm is
doing in the real world using in the elf
of our of our client-side developer we
implemented the logistic regression
prediction prediction equation in Java
so this is a Java code but since we are
all Python developers we can just skip
it and this is the interesting part
so after implementing the equation in
Java
I now realize okay great now I can
create a mechanism of online tagging
meaning I now can collect a lot of
negative data that will help me to
improve the algorithm faster and this is
actually one of our applications quick
and this is the the virtual button that
we created so that allows me to tag
quickly the negative examples meaning if
there is a constant flow of negative
samples if they are actually not
negative actually button push I can
confirm them and tag them other examples
are automatically tagged by the
by the application to be negative so I
can like this collect a lot of data and
come back and train my model again
another thing that I realized was that
now not only that I can do online
tagging I also could do online learning
personalized only learning for the user
that wear the watch so you can see here
just a simple mathematical equation that
updates online the logistic regression
equation and that helps me helps me not
only thinking of the algorithm as
offline algorithm but actually improve
my coefficients while going while
wearing to watch so when I decided to do
with all those great ideas is to go to a
grandma on weekend and experiment with
her I wanted to see actually how I
elderly people can if they find and push
correctly the button and my grandma did
very well and she has a lot of patience
so we collected a lot of positive data
while she was cooking sitting laying
eating and all kind of normal activities
meanwhile we also collected massive
amount of negative data do you think
there was a happy end for this product
this one that alarm I just said it by
pushing the butter yeah god it's not my
solution actually sorry
actually after we push the what provider
enough and manage to think about
together with us about a solution that
set the alarm so so despite the tragic
and for my solution I actually learned a
lot from this project because now I
understand very well the client side of
the project I experienced with group
cross validation I had great ideas for
other projects of us and the most
important thing I'm here to lecture you
about this project in PI data thank you
there's someone has any questions yes a
little big spikes when it vibrates yes
so if you do the derivatives and then
just put a threshold yeah so I didn't
explain not that they're evidence but
what I did is just put all the numbers
into their absolute values this mainly
algorithm learn much better
any other questions yeah yeah I also saw
about us I actually wanted to do it next
didn't got to it but the reason that I
started from the logistic regression as
as i explained was that i didn't know
where it's going to be implemented and
for me to take a I don't know deep
learning package and then to try to
implement it on the phone it's probably
pretty hard so I just wanted to start
with a simple model anyway
I didn't get to it either because I said
and I am another thing that I thought
was that actually it was reasonable to
think that the pattern of the signals of
the of my future will ever like probably
linear or some simple correlation with
the outcome okay so I didn't want to
start and try difficult model before and
finish to explore and simple one I
thought that what I saw that what really
happy is adding more data cleaning it
thinking about thinking about how to
make the positive set larger okay thank
you
[Applause]